[Musik]
innerhalb von zwei sekunden wenn
überhaupt sehr minimal gebrauchsfähig
[Musik]
ich habe einen beruf springen und in dem
moment geschossen setzte den kopf
geschossen
[Musik]
es geht mit sicherheit dass man nicht
schutzlos ausgeliefert ist
[Musik]
dass ich für mehr saubere waffen wählen
hat zeigen die kapitäne aus was passiert
ist
immer schon mit
einmal im jahr schlagen in lausanne die
herzen der waffenliebhaber höher
es sind vor allem männer die es an die
waffen börse zieht
wer will kann hier gleich einen
waffenerwerbsschein beantragen
fast in allen kantonen haben die gesuche
für den waffenerwerb stark zugenommen
hansruedi da hinten besitzt bereits
mehrere pistolen und revolver nicht
zuletzt für seine sicherheit wie er sagt
dahinten von allen nur da die genannt
ist seit seiner zeit dem militär von
waffen fasziniert damals habe man noch
stolze auf die armee sein können sagte
er
heute sei das anders gewehre die man im
liegen schießt kann er wegen
knieproblemen nicht mehr benutzen
wenn ihm das cornet fr
was fasziniert sie eigentlich hoffen
einfach süß sahen sie die chance
[Musik]
in seinem schlafzimmer der bart der
zweifache familienvater seine
schießeisen auf
es wird sehr schnell zur waffe griff es
vermehrt zu tätigen
die who familie und hatte auch früher
schon mal zeit wo ich hätte noch linak
sie sind wie dem der mieter verlangt der
nachbarn reinisch und denn wird diese
maschinen zur waffe griff
schlachters carmen spielmann ist
büchsenmacher im sankt gallischen
challes seine spezialität sturmgewehre
veredeln
also so sind neben ihr steht für 750 mio
wo mir auch hat und wie jährige
blackbeard das sind piloten die chance
zu einer rechten präzisionswaffen worden
wo kunden sehr erfolgreich einschüssen
mit einer sehr viel freude leid mit dem
ich sage ich nur dass qualität verkaufen
die lebensqualität sieht spielmann aber
grundsätzlich bedroht die welt habe sich
zum schlechten verändert meint er
leider denn natürlich der haut überall
fanny setzte zum andere beherrscht
darum finde ich sein coach war mir
bewaffnet werden weil er schwer
bewaffnet sind haben es gemacht oder die
gemacht wie ein krimineller
wo sich vorher tobe waffen mit bösen
absichten im sinn und mädels schutzlos
ausgeliefert sind also jeder darf mit
den schweizern laufen dass meine sie ja
ich finde das wort dass jeder werde
spart von der wartung von mitmenschen
elektroautos rudolf und armee hat man
das gefühl es ist mit mio aber das hören
und rom staatsanwalt extras für wählen
diese baut man konflikt habe mit ein und
war für die beatles zurück mit waffen
ausgebildet ist und das braucht er sehr
groß ich fünfter beherrsche ich möchte
sagen dass man aber auf eis
was war überhaupt da ist es leichter
aber von einem harten jahr gespart
[Musik]
unbeschwert durchs leben tanzen fernab
von angst und sorgen
doch wenn die füße still stehen sind
sich die kursteilnehmerinnen und
kursteilnehmer einig das leben ist keine
party wir sehen ja sogar schon mal so
eine situation ist das also schwere her
dass wir brauchen schulen oder urin
stinkt das ist möglich
[Musik]
mit dem kabinett lee sagt sie fühle sich
nicht mehr so sicher daheim wie früher
auslöser war der vierfachmord im
aargauischen rupperswil die medizinische
pflegeassistentin wohnt unweit des
tatorts oder machen werden
dolly buster sehen und ich dass ich mich
schon immer so laut gefühle nach der
folge geschockt bin ich aber dass ich
einfach sicherheit haben da die heim
dass man hier doch bis man sich so viel
passiert in der nachbarschaft
wo der mord passierte und einfach das
passiert immer mehr die offene grenzen
und alles drum und dran das macht mir
sorgen und ich möchte mich einfach
ich möchte mich einfach sicher fühlen da
die ein remis was machen sie denn man
jetzt noch zweiter hinter der tür würde
gab hugo rolle und wird dekoriert
erschwert
und wenn ich keine antwort über hunger
aus der schweiz vielleicht verhindert
weil ich da meine kleine antwort
überhaupt wird im beruf machen die wahl
vergeben die ganze sicherheit dass ich
weiß wenn man ihr fachwissen wird dass
ich die woche dem könnte zeigen
sowas würde sehr süße mit ihrem
bedürfnis eine waffe zu kaufen ist sie
nicht alleine
im vergangenen jahr stiegen erneut in
fast allen kantonen die gesuche für
waffenerwerbsschein uri und genf
verzeichneten fast 50 prozent mehr
anträge zu den spitzenreitern zählt auch
der kanton aargau hier gingen über 40
prozent mehr gesuche ein der letzten
jahre die waffenerwerbsschein zurück
neid das ist das gesteigert hat und
insbesondere mehr genug dass immer mehr
frauen den waffenerwerb sie sich
erkundigen 20 stellen aber eine
begründung oder nachvollziehbar ist ein
schwieriges und das sagt ja was der
grund ist warum es gerade frauen zu
schaffen oder nicht
da kann ich hatte gründe gehabt peter
meyer ist fasziniert von waffen er
kaufte sich immer wieder einmal eine
dazu seinen schatz bunkert er im keller
er hat einen wert von über 20.000
franken
das ist normale schloss das im
stahlrahmen sind tot sorgen
so sind leuchtend report also soll ich
sehr schwierig zur sprache das ist
dominiere wahlversammlung als die
private stück ist schritt um unsere wolf
durch sogenanntes interaction spezielle
waffen sicher perkussionsrevolver dabei
wollen wir ebenso also damals einfach
nur drei han die chance an
eine ganze seite nach revolver schon
drin ist dass man die patronen noch
alles selber machen und zweitens ich
doch russell schöne woche hätte in
nußbach
ich glaube das ist lösbar und die
wunderschöne griff 46 waffen zieren
seine sammlung etliche benutzt er an
schießwettbewerben ich weiß es ist ja
als geglüht ihre clique zustand wenn sie
aufhören aber für mich sind das kann die
waffe in dem sinne ist intonieren prof
die einzige trophäe goldmedaille meyer
sammelt nicht nur waffen sondern auch
munition und die dazu passende literatur
interessiert mich das seminar meter
geschoss hall ab und bmw mit oft auf
mich ist uns gut geschult und das geht
glatter durchschuss und hinter trauer
besteht kann tödlich getroffen hatte
[Musik]
firmen spielmann ist nicht nur wegen der
freude am singen mitglied eines juden
vereins dem 56 jährigen geht es vor
allem um die erhaltung der schweizer
kultur junge mitglieder mit nachwuchs
und wir haben große anderem an der hu
verübt das hat muss er vorderhand so
vielen großteil von der bevölkerung sich
den metallen hinter dem sozialen zweig
wandelte sich im verein kinder wobei
gerade die er sieht sich im verein
bekleiden kann sich integrieren
so steht das gerade eine integrations
gilt ein zweig aus so dass die
gesellschaft der doppelte gesellschaft
wo er ist aber für dieses kulturprogramm
und aber immer mehr auf der bank wären
[Musik]
wow
auch da die da hinten fühlt sich in
seiner heimat immer mehr zur seite
gedrängt
[Musik]
was ich denn näheres idealbild fertig
mit so ist vielleicht vor 20 30
[Musik]
doch trainer wir sind sicher es sind sie
und das aus einem zeitlebens schon wohnt
er im selben dorf nach der schulzeit
lernte er heizungs sanitär
später arbeitete er in einer gießerei
wegen rückenproblemen musste da hinten
seine arbeit aufgeben und so wurde er im
alter von 57 jahren zum iv bezüger heute
mit 66 blickt eher sorgenvoll in die
zukunft
russland der schweiz jenseits von gut
und böse einzig fühlst du darfst wie zu
unsicher
schon sicher für sich ist ein früheres
idol des office passieren aber mit
sophos landes haben für juli tand angst
und zwar sehr große angst ist dass
berechtigte angst sie den zauberstab ist
negativ sein aber vielleicht trocken
märz griff ist es nicht kann es denn so
schludrig verboten sind bekannt aber man
muss doch harry van see locken und und
sieht die glas und den ich mich
orientiert und ich glaube nicht dass sie
den braten und magister geschrieben
das muss hart bestraft seine
einschätzung alles werde immer schlimmer
steht im widerspruch zur statistik
seit mehreren jahren sinken in der
schweiz die registrierten straftaten
beispielsweise der kanton aargau
hier wurden 2016 im vergleich zum
vorjahr 10 prozent weniger delikte
begangen
trotzdem glauben viele dass die
kriminalität zunehmen
natürlich hat rief losbricht geschaut
ich muss sich vorstelle wenigen werden
impfstoff da die öffentliche ruhe denn
wird das vieh multipliziert oder für
medikamente kürzen radio und ließen oder
entsprechende soziale netzwerk und da
geht das ein multiplikator und befindet
sich oben sicherer
obwohl straftat ist oft der name die
optik kriminalstatistik für sein so dass
man sich sicher fühlt weiter unsicher
ich bin jetzt sicher stimmt es ist so
dass sowohl betrugs lande kriminalität
wie auch bei der allgemeine statistik
vor der kriminalität sind zahlen
rückläufig
also für mich für mich ist es eigentlich
ganz anders also nicht hören was ich
gesehen
für mich ist es wird immer schlimmer
[Musik]
im bernischen burgdorf besucht die
46-jährige das waffengeschäft von daniel
wies um sich beraten zu lassen
[Musik]
doch die patrone von wintour nicht nur
über die proben vor schwank und witzig
die waffe bereits gerade wenn die ganz
schnell selbst verteidigungsfall der
mache ich also innerhalb von
sekundenbruchteilen kantone zeigt das
web bereits eine vollkommen ohne
potenzielle mieter die patrone so
genannt die man stoff patronen
verschossen
da geht das einfacher immer verschollen
um den steuervorschlag es geht der
wichtige punkt dürfte zur übernahme der
sondern fußball war vermutlich die
münster voll zu ihrer verteidigung
setzte er ganz für sich und konnte mit
dem ersten europa-rennen der gesetzgeber
notwendig ist okay dass man einfach
nicht selten geschieht ja das war
notwehr aktiven ganz chance das ist
völlig glaube die dort fragen zum kauf
einer faustfeuerwaffe konnte sich gabi
niggli noch nicht entschließen
sie muss ohnehin zuerst einen auszug aus
dem strafregister beantragen
das game zum konto der kanton look der
strafregisterauszug der kanton nur den
polizisten der kanton nicht gut gemeint
und nachher wird der offene wagen
entweder ausgestellt und ablehnungsgrund
waren apple mehrfach vorbestraft ist
wenn er brauche heute drogenproblem hat
oder wenn wenn man muss sich selber oder
andere metapher würdig werden also bis
bedrohen kann
[Musik]
die witzige und herzlich begrüßt
dabei zahlt und die freunde da ist die
führende politische dorf begleitet
schieß vereine haben in der schweiz eine
lange tradition
diese schützengesellschaft aus baden
wurde vor 550 jahren gegründet
der ausflug führt die gesellschaft nach
appenzell
in der schweiz gibt es über 3.000 chips
vereinen fast jedes wochenende treffen
sich deren mitglieder
sie trainieren zusammen und nehmen an
schießwettbewerben teil
ich danke gegründet
wichtige veranstaltung unternehmen
gemeinsam das machen ganz bewusst die
meisten schützenvereine verzeichneten in
den letzten jahren einen
mitgliederschwund weil die badener
bewusst den nachwuchs fördern sind sie
aber davon nicht betroffen
am nächsten tag fliegt blei durch die
luft mihajlo kink l schießt seit einem
jahr für den 16 jährigen gymnasiasten
hat das schießen etwas meditatives und
die ganz viel mechanischen finger wo wir
machen also wohl helfen
für die schützen ist schießen ein sport
und das gewehr ein sportgerät die
restliche welt spricht von waffen deren
gebrauch strenger limitiert werden müsse
unter den schützen herrscht aufruhr
sie erwarten schlimmes von der eu diese
berät nach den verschiedenen anschlägen
über strengere richtlinien
davon wäre auch die schweiz als schengen
staat betroffen
die badener schützen sind ratlos
schärfere waffen richtlinien würden nur
die anständigen bürger bestrafen glauben
sie ich weiß nicht was man die
schützenfreunde könnte ich möchte das
noch vor gesetze verschärfen wenig tut
mir in brüssel entscheidet mitunter
bevölkerung entworfen das dreifache
schritt nun mit dem wert nur die legung
auch für die wurde in street sind aus
dem verkehr zogen um nicht die illegal
dass ich da fand ich sage dass das mit
dem gesetz beschäftigt in brüssel
arbeitete man eineinhalb jahre lang an
den neuen feuerwaffen richtlinien
sie beinhalten unter anderem ein verbot
für halbautomatische waffen mit mehr als
zehn schuss sportschützen und anerkannte
sammler sollen aber eine
ausnahmebewilligung beantragen dürfen
sie müssen nachweisen dass sie mitglied
eines schützenvereins sind und
regelmäßig an schießwettbewerben
teilnehmen
es gab ein problem mit dem europäischen
gesetz da gehört die schweiz dazu mit
den vollautomatischen waffen die auf
halbautomatik umgerüstet werden können
sie konnten in der eu ohne waffenschein
gekauft und verkauft werden
wir haben diese gesetzeslücke
geschlossen weil diese waffen in die
hände von terroristen gelangten weg fort
arbeitete federführend an den neuen
richtlinien
die britin ist präsidentin des
ausschusses für binnenmarkt und
verbraucherschutz
sie hält fest dass für die schweiz eine
ausnahmeregelung vorgesehen ist
so dürfen soldaten ihr sturmgewehr nach
geleisteter dienstpflicht weiterhin nach
hause nehmen wenn sie aktive
sportschützen sind es gibt
verschärfungen im europäischen
waffengesetz aber es liegt in der hand
der schweiz die richtlinien für den
waffengebrauch festzulegen
das ist meine botschaft wir haben der
schweiz die möglichkeit gegeben ihren
bürgern die erlaubnis zu erteilen wenn
sie einen bedarf nachweisen können
die schweizer regierung bestimmt nicht
das europäische gesetz mitte märz
stimmte das eu parlament der neuen
richtlinie zu
sie soll 2020 in kraft treten zwei jahre
später muss die schweiz gemäss
schengen-vertrag nachziehen
sie erhält von brüssel bei der konkreten
umsetzung viel freiraum
[Musik]
nun ist also bern am zug
bereits jetzt mobilisiert sich
widerstand gegen jegliche änderung des
bestehenden waffenrechts politiker wie
jakob büchler aus dem kanton st gallen
sind die hoffnung von german spielmann
der cvp nationalrat ist beim
büchsenmacher ein gern gesehener gast
dieser verspricht alles notwendige zu
unternehmen um den gefahren abzuwenden
schweiz hat damals 2005 wurde das
schengen-abkommen vors volk gebracht hat
hat sie so genannt die sonderregelung
für tweets uns konkret ihr konto soll
bis juni ka andrej anzeichen gehört dass
das nach wie vor gültig werden aber der
nächste session mit der frau sommaruga
ihr geld diskutiert wie vor ihrer küste
ist das nur in kraft gibt es wieder
flüssig kann bis jetzt kann die usa
wirklich kommt sicher so wenn so nicht
wäre dann müsste man natürlich der
politische schritte auch die basis
bereitet sich auf den ernstfall vor
wir haben 130 30 schützen in der schweiz
wo aktiv saison betriebe das sind schon
mal 130 unterschriften nur von
referendum und einem toyota in seiner
sammlung
chantal galladé ist die wohl bekannteste
gegnerin der schweizer waffen szenen der
vater der nationalrätin nahm sich mit
der armeewaffe das leben
es ist aber möglicherweise grund warum
ich immer wieder aufgestanden weil ich
habe selber betroffen weil ich das
selber erlebt hat die sp politikerin ist
mitglied der sicherheitspolitischen
kommission
sie wird an vorderster front an der
umsetzung der neuen eu richtlinien für
die schweiz arbeiten vom politisch es
war ein arbeitssieg sportgerät ich man
kann sich aber auch detailfragen mit
ihren zelten rausgeschmissen weil sich
auf dem heimweg und damit unter der
machen
aber von mir aus weil es politisch nicht
möglich
das können sie auch es wäre schon mal in
diesem winter sicherheit war
sportschütze die äcker und politisch
verständlich aber verheiratet
schusswaffe nützen im auto gemüt niemand
darf es überhaupt zu setzen und wann
sich jetzt wartet dann noch einmal sind
sie auch vor oder tötet und fordert er
macht überhaupt greifen dass manche
fotos alte schulhof
die schweiz hat einen der höchsten
waffen dichten pro kopf sie steht an
vierter stelle hinter den usa nehmen und
serbien 2 millionen schusswaffen werden
in schweizer haushalten aufbewahrt
schätzt der bund davon eine halbe
million armeewaffen ein armeegewehr war
es auch mit dem sich der ehemann von
doris l das leben nahm der mann von
doris elfer offizier im militär und
bewahrte seine waffe daheim auf markus l
litt an depressionen und war suizidal
veranlagt so ganz für mich einem vita
und du musst dir hilfe suchen und erich
den ins schlafzimmer hinterher und
zurück mit dem sturmgewehr und er froh
ist mit der waffe handelt muss ich
sterbe das ist so sehr stücks event oder
kopf gott will wir sehr viel wurde und
den sind das millisekunde also wo meine
mannschaft ist also wenn man das eher so
mittel einsetzte die waffen und ein
tolles und denn ich geschossen und je
nach dem monat trifft sind riesig
zusammen und was man den saal auf das
kommen wir nicht erklären also das
passiert da ich weiß einfach dass ich
weit weg 7 und frau habe einfach
geschrieben und jetzt will ich einen
ziemlichen rinker und ich bin in uster
wallisellen und haben mir denn
[Musik]
in der phase als sie am anfang wird und
was heute noch ich mit wird ist immer
wenn seine kinder gottes wo er in das
info entscheide gefällt werden
ich denke sehr große worte bekommen ja
aber ich lege mich einfach gut und mit
den kindergarten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
solche tragödien möchte chantal galladé
verhindern
auf unsere initiative hin hat sich die
politikerin bereit erklärt sich mit
german spiel mann zutreffen der
büchsenmacher und vertreter der waffen
szene wird von seiner lebenspartnerin
begleitet mit einer op 200 früheren 400
fuß war für mich ein großer teil zieht
und das muss nicht weniger schlimm weil
jeder schusswaffe tote ist einer zu viel
weiß über tvo getankt hat oder aber
ausscheidungs der walz co
die können früher oder später sowieso
befinde sich mit der waffe sei ist immer
noch einer oder eine 10 bringt ich
besserung braucht außer auf china und
unschuldiger hoch führen nach rom vor
die stehzeit wird wegen fahrlässiger
tötung von der person obwohl er keine
machen das passiert braucht die starke
und die sie durch hat sich das bei mir
jetzt die 200 bringen schusswaffe
vernichtet wurde
ja dann könnt ihr 200
sie sagt eine musikwelle umbringen macht
sowieso groß realer später dass ich eben
mit worden das zeigt wirklich die ganze
befragung auf menschen und
suizidversuche belegt haben dass wenn
sie immer fakt sich an welle töten und
man hat sich eine hätte sie nicht doch
sie nachher das fiel das nicht noch mal
wiederholen
[Musik]
ich sage dass ich der meinung bin dass
waffe wäre im besitz von waffen ischen
zu vital ist das viel schneller die
woche einen bruchteil der techno
fortbewegen im sinn von einem rücklauf
aber gut weil sich unter zu klicken
die bucht einfach irgendwie noch immer
und ich denke mit der waffe dass ich
einfach kurzschluss per se also ein
suizid ist immer ein kurzschluss aber
mit der waffe machen muss einfach viel
schneller mit spielzeug und da stimme
fasziniert
ich muss es so sagen es ist mit
ausgleich es ist mit der waffe so sich
mit dem gaucho und sich mit der frau
ohne so hier und ich könnte mit dem go
siemens-titel oc&c zweimal als obmann
eines pistolen clubs achtet da die da
hinten darauf dass im schiessstand die
vorschriften eingehalten werden
aber in gewissen situationen würde er
seine persönliche sicherheit über das
gesetz stehen 50 franken betragen
da macht man sei einfach aber sehe dann
illegal noch nötige ja natürlich
die liga war das ist nicht illegal so
viel egal
ja ich muss einfach sagen was so hück
wird sie vielleicht schon aber mit dem
lager magazin
[Musik]
peter meyer ist gleich in zwei vereinen
mitglied regelmäßig trainiert er im
schützenhaus härtli in spreitenbach für
wettkämpfe düsseldorf nicht mehr
verdient in der schützenstube war
munition hat du im schießstand ist meyer
der chef als schützenmeister hat er das
sagen
euro erhöht die rollos training und
schreit aber auch es ist nicht einfach
für mich schließt verbaut sein und dann
braucht es zeigt dass ich geschichte
schießt vom mittwoch ja ich weiß du
musst wissen was parallel schwender
heißt und papier klar und trocken
als schützenmeister muss man
gewissenhaft sein sagt meyer denn jeder
vorfall mit einer schusswaffe werfe
sofort ein schlechtes licht auf alle
schützen wenige kilometer vom
schützenhaus entfernt im wald der
aargauischen gemeinde fislisbach an
dieser stelle erschoss im vergangenen
sommer ein 17 jähriger einen 18 jährigen
kollegen
es stellte sich heraus dass der täter
ein ehemaliger jungschütze war im
schützenhaus härtli spreitenbach treffen
sich die jungschützen um gewehre zu
putzen
dass sein ehemaliger jungschütze aus der
region mit seiner waffe seinen kollegen
tötete beschäftigte jungen
sie sagt mir ziehen
warum nicht also mit der jungen die mit
paul tatwaffe da und niveau über 60 sind
der trafalgar verschluss also das ding
noch zu schießen
das gibt doch das geht nicht mit hacke
und das sei nicht möglich
ja es ist es ist einfach tragisch mit
orte umgang mit dem sportgerät und der
passiert so ziehen dass selbst eben
nicht passieren teppich sagt spurt auf
der spur rekordversuch abtöten ich mich
das schon bewusst nie heimisch man sich
bewusst für das geht es um die erfolge
und sicherheitsvorschriften regelmäßig
über
oft werde bei jugendlichen boomt der
schießsport fast 10.000 teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmer absolvierten im
vergangenen jahr einen jungschützen kurs
ein drittel mehr als 2000 15
was nicht an faszination ist alles nur
show vom kuchen wende verbrannt
im vergangenen jahr wurde das
mindestalter für jungschützen von 17 auf
15 gesägt german spielmann würde noch
viel jüngeren eine waffe geben
ich würde ihm raten um haben wir nicht
hin bringen was aber auch wenn ist dass
das nichts berühren nützt nur hatte mit
also es muss der plan sie natürlich
nicht
das müsse im urlaub machen ist es immer
irgendwie bist du also besonders habe
bobadilla 12 auf finnisch schusswaffe
schaffens mechanisches gefährlich sie
mit fallstudien oder und darum sage ich
einmal im rat will
es gibt viele leute die haben vielleicht
visionen machen und mit einer bösartig
wind steht überall im leben darum solle
die chance nötig leiters und tricks wie
man das kind unruhig geben ritalin ruhig
schlafen kann ich meine erwartung ist
aktiv vielleicht vor wunderwaffe wo sie
damit erzielen können sie haben einfach
regenrennen und sich entwickeln so nennt
sie am markt reagieren
schusswaffe bei bedarf reagieren sondern
es billiger so inszeniert dass du zu
erkennen zu dessen wahlkreis lassen
der hauptmann weiterfahrt das ist
natürlich ein pathologischer fortschritt
wurden das macht und ich an ein anderes
verständnis von hinter erzählen ich
musste das spiel logik erschließt sich
mir nicht eine schusswaffe mit biss
verloren
die kinder haben
waffen begleiten den menschen schon seit
jeher peter meyer schaut sie im
landesmuseum zürich die geschichte von
dreieinhalb tausend jahren an finnische
kultur und das gen in sich länder
entwickelt hinter menschheit dass man
hoffen entwickelt konstruiert hat zum
york auto show damals stammte moment
beträgt hand und hand sie nur durch die
gleiche waffe wo man mit die ecke lockt
natürlich gegenden gegnerin gesetz ein
zwangsläufiger seine eigenen
kulturschätze hortet meyer im keller in
der wohnung sind sie tabu soll seiner
frau zuliebe seit 48 jahren sind die
beiden verheiratet
also pc lesen aber wenn es zu viel essig
große eher ungern ziehen gelder ab macht
mir hat das nicht unbedingt angst habe
ich seine gefühle seit seiner
pensionierung hat der 75-jährige viel
zeit für sein hobby einmal in der woche
arbeitet er noch als instruktorin einem
schießkeller oft nimmt er erfolgreich an
wettkämpfen teil
seine munition stellte er selber her wie
viel zeit verbringen sie dann da ohne
ihren ruhm ja das ist ganz
unterschiedlich
es sind sich mehrere sturm der im topf
monitor und ablauf ich konflikt am
morgen um 10 uhr begann mein sofa isst
isst zu mittag und dann gleich wieder
haben und seit 1 tagesschau ist für mich
wichtigste moment im fernsehen
da bin ich auch die wieder doppelsalto
nicht nur mich bist du schwanger bist
wichtig seien ihr müsst ihr nur hollmann
drehtag wacker weg und müssen also sie
sehen den waffen kann dann war für
sommer kann man da sagen sie sind auch
in wasser nach waffen
das habe ich nie gern das wort will es
gibt sicher offenen augen erzählen diese
institution
der größte teil von tierschützer wo der
sport für sport seriös betrieb wenn man
die waffen aber nennt man nicht als
beleidigung
[Musik]
aber es gibt sie waffennarren
da muss gut die oder hoch dieser mann
besitzt über 40 waffen ein paar stehen
bei ihm daheim geladen herum
die sind gute zogen sie sind in sicherer
wenn man wisse dass ministerin wäre so
wichtig dass sie sich äußert sich an der
waffe könnte ich wäre ja was beliebt war
verlor nur eine schlaufe bewilligten
linksextreme bedroht also was konkret
haben zwei patrone geschickt zwei google
ebenso attraktive artikel geschrieben
hat die rechte und vor allem gebrochen
aber mein geschmack so schwierig dass y
nachdem ein psychiater den mann
begutachtet hatte erhielt er seine
waffen wieder zurück deutschen spring
stunde
die waffen können wieder erteilt werden
ohne jegliche gefährdung
stell dir mal vor ich bin auch viel
normaler aus die eu zu sagen jungs was
sie da gemacht haben eine großartige
show gemacht mit der fia probieren lütz
belegen
[Musik]
aufbewahrungs ruhm sichergestellte waffe
haben
zum konkreten fall nehmen die behörden
keine stellung mediensprecher roland
pfister erklärt indes unter welchen
bedingungen jemand beschlagnahmte waffen
wieder zurückerhält
der grund das private zurück und ist
wenn man auch zu beurteilen und hat vor
- das ist ja langwierige upgrade das
haus unter umständen sich auch das
gutachten zugrunde liegt wobei urteil
dass die personen im völlig ist
beschuldigt oder betroffen ist das auch
kein rechtsmittel ergriffen eine echte
instanz co und dass wir diesen verfahren
abgewendet und sich am schluss eine
beurteilung losen es ist jedem fall
natürlich wieder zurück er wird unter
beurteilung vor lied von der unabhängige
stelle kommen der fußballs zu großer
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das mit dem auto
zurück das krad fahrer muss gott aber
das restrisiko besteht wirklich
das hinaus was ich muss ja die schweizer
hausfrau museums stelle abgeben
nun zum sagen jedes masse wenn ganze 20
jeder fünfte jeder habe er mit dem stück
so stevens natürlich ein anderes stand
das waffengesetzt werde jetzt hochwasser
wird immer wieder genannt nur an jäger
gestanden und zwar im alltag also muss
man jene gebiete im gegensatz zu der
schuss war verbrauchsmaterial tag zum
beispiel der für den us ordnungshütern
sage nicht alle risiken ausschließen
sagte nun da wo keiner ist wie bei der
schusswaffe machte zins verbieten weil
man sie vieles anders
gabi niggli hat sich entschieden
sie will sich notfalls schützen können
und kaufte sich eine pistole sowie das
momentan genau gezeigt dass richtig in
der hand das ist so fertig gestellt
einfach nicht nicht probiert heftig
wegen macht man das ist absolut daheim
war die 46 jährige ihre pistole in einem
tresor auf unerreichbar für ihre
enkelkinder
wie fühlen sie sich jetzt dass jetzt der
bauverein haushalt hat sich für mich
aber immer noch ließ komisches gefühl
gewesen noch nie sagen aber ich kann
alles packt vorteil
ich fühl mich gut also dass kurzfristig
sehr gemacht sicherheit durch
waffenbesitz so wie es in einzelnen
staaten der usa praktiziert wird das
wünscht sich büchsenmacher spielmann für
die schweiz zum beispiel lehrer bewarfen
sie gesund und ging sieben passiert so
behaupte verloren ist in ordnung bringen
120 anderer und bringt
und das ist schaue in frank rieger so in
einer krippe oder einfach die die luft
hatte siemens dekra hat wohin schuss
verkauf will ich sende werden sondern
steht als man sofort wo von attentätern
heute schießen das ist unsere große
feier ihres mancher bild und sicherheit
spielen macht mir angst
das ist absurd dass das erhöht doch
einfach das risiko dass es tote gibt das
umfeld und das ist ja wahnsinnig und
dann fühlt sich eine bedroht und nehmen
sie führen und unsere knopf dann droht
und lehrern hat und dann noch eine
identität für wichtig dass ich nicht
dass sicherheit hergestellt das ist das
werk wurde
auch wenn die kriminalität zurückgeht
menschen wie gabi nick li sind überzeugt
dass die gefahren zu nehmen
fakten können dagegen nichts ausrichten
gegen die macht der gefühle ist mancher
wehrlos
[Musik]
j